perovskite is one of the most common
crystal structures found on the planet
but common doesn't mean boring while it
was originally discovered as a mineral
this amazing crystal shape shows up
everywhere and is a common subject for
cutting-edge scientific research for
starters earth scientists are fascinated
with it
because even though it's the most
abundant kind of mineral on the planet
we hardly ever see it most of it is
buried deep within the Earth's mantle
profs kites make up 93 percent of the
lower Mantle's mass and 38 percent of
the total mass of the planet there are
several different kinds of props kite
but they each share of similar dense
crystalline structure in the mantle
silicate profs kites are the most common
the high density of these minerals
create the sharp boundary at a depth of
six hundred sixty kilometres that
separates the less dense upper mantle
from the more dense perovskite rich
lower mantle below 2,600 kilometers the
pressure crushes silica perovskites into
a new mineral called post spur off Skype
post froth Skype is mechanically weaker
but has a higher electrical conductivity
that allows pockets of the mineral to
interact with Earth's magnetic field
researchers theorize that all
terrestrial planets bigger than Mars
have a similar abundance of perovskites
deep beneath their surface so mapping
out these mineral transitions allows us
to not only learn more about the
internal structure of our planet but
other planets as well perovskites knack
for conductivity brings to the fore
another quirk that makes it the perfect
target for research metal halide
perovskites are a type of crystal that
can act as a semi conductor so
scientists are looking at how it can be
incorporated into various technologies
in 2009 researchers discovered that by
shedding light on perovskite they were
able to induce a small electric charge
creating a miniscule solar cell since
then
the efficiency of prof. Skype based
solar cells has increased to over 22%
these panels generate electricity via a
thin layer of lead halide perovskites
film on top of a coating of conductive
oxide one of the benefits using profs
kites and solar cells is their defect
tolerance unlike silicon cells where
everything has to be aligned perfectly
to work and any damage renders the
entire device unusable perovskite cells
can be simply layered onto a surface and
generate an electric charge making
manufacturing easier and cheaper but
while engineers are hopeful that
perovskite could help to bring down the
price of solar energy they have some
downsides for now the probe skite cells
are small fragile and degrade much
faster than conventional silicon crystal
panels on the order of hours and days
instead of years
if prof Skype can take in light could it
also make it researchers are looking
into improving screens and LEDs using
LED halide perovskites
as quantum dot nano crystals on an LCD
TV screen pixels are made up of three
colors red green and blue tests with
prototype perovskite pixels use a single
kind of light source blue LEDs with
probe skite polymer beads on top to
control the color when the blue light
shines through the beads the color of
the light that makes it through comes
out in a green or red hue while silicon
quantum dot displays are out on the
market already they are very expensive
so like solar panels using halide
perovskites
could bring down the cost of
manufacturing immensely the colors
created by this prof skype prototype
exceeded some television and computer
monitor standards good enough for use in
a future TV even though each of these
uses has some roadblocks to adoption the
massive increase in research and studies
about perovskite means we'll be seeing a
lot of this crystal structure in the
years to come
you